Мамо...
Мені тебе бракує..
Мені тебе теж бракує.
Дуже...
Я відключаюся, гаразд?
Ок.
Коли вона померла?
Три роки тому.
Воскресіння матері як цифрового чат-бота - це революція, яку здійснили молоді засновники стартапу.
Тепер вони хочуть перепродати свій чат-бот компанії, яка створює людські голограми - цифрові клони.
Схрещення цих двох технологій разом обіцяє мільярдний бізнес.
Дія фільму "Вихід" відбувається у 2047 році і виглядає як наукова фантастика. Однак частина цих ідей вже нині є реальністю.
Технологічні компанії вже давно експериментують зі штучним інтелектом, будують нейронні мережі, створюють машини, які вміють самонавчатися,
самостійно діяти та реагувати. І - вони вже давно розпізнали фінансовий потенціал смерті. Змінюється суспільство - змінюються і традиції.
А з ними - і наше ставлення до смерті. Наприклад, траур на цвинтарі видається доречним дедалі меншій кількості людей.
У цифровій галузі відкривається цілий напрямок, який займається саме цими питаннями. Розробники запитують: можливо, потрібні нові пропозиції.
Можливо, має сенс для людей після смерті залишити щось для контакту з найближчими родичами.
Джеймс Влахос, наприклад, заснував компанію "HereAfter".
Коли його батько захворів на рак, він зберігав для чат-бота інформацію про нього: короткі повідомленнями та аудіозаписи батька.
"Тато-бот" навчився спілкуватися так, як це робив його батько. І Влахос перетворив це на бізнес-модель.
Тепер люди за абонентську плату можуть надсилати історії чатів або відео своїх коханих зі смартфонів.
З цих даних створюється чат-бот з голосом померлого.
Чи стикаєтеся з якимись великими проблемами у своєму житті зараз? - Так...
Іноді вам просто потрібна маленька перспектива. Не могли б ви заспівати мені пісню? Звісно.
Компанія Vive Studios з Південної Кореї йде на крок далі і обіцяє майже "цифрове воскресіння".
На своєму вебсайті вона демонструє поєднання чат-бота померлої дівчини з проекцією семирічної дівчини.
Мати може фактично відсвяткувати день народження з нею за допомогою окулярів віртуальної реальності та датчиків на руках.
Скільки заплатять люди в траурі, які сумують за такими моментами?
І як це впливає на родичів померлих?
Ось чому потрібно дуже уважно спостерігати, щоб зрозуміти, що відбувається з цими клієнтами, хто опікується цими клієнтами.
Як родичів може травмувати віртуальний клон померлої людини. А якщо вони вже не можуть диференціювати, що є реальністю, а що - віртуальність?
Психологи також описують, що можна отримати патологічне горе.
У певному сенсі ми маємо справу з відкритим експериментом, який, звичайно, є надзвичайно сумнівним і небезпечним,
і всіх причетних необхідно запитати, чи можуть вони нести цю відповідальність і чи усвідомлюють вони це.
Однак, мабуть, доведеться розглядати це в кожному конкретному випадку
і не можна цілковито засуджувати такі підходи щодо перенесення культури жалоби в цифровий простір.
Для того, щоб настільки пеерконливо використовувати штучний інтелект, потрібні дані. Багато особистих даних.
Науковці з Оксфордського університету у Великобританії досліджують, як великі технологічні компанії мають обходитися з такими масивами даних.
Чому користувачі зазвичай віддають свої дані добровільно? Чи відомо їм про небезпеку? Ці питання досліджують в Інституті етики штучного інтелекту.
Штучний інтелект може бути надзвичайно руйнівним для суспільства, він може бути сексистським, расистським та вкрай несправедливим.
Приклад: Microsoft запустила у 2016 році чат-бот Tей, який самостійно спілкувався у Twitter.
Лише через один день діяльність Тей довелося припинити, оскільки твіти чат-бота були сексистськими та расистськими.
Тей ображав інших користувачів і став антисемітом. Що трапиться, якщо у ​​майбутньому себе так почнуть поводити також цифрові клони людей?
Штучний інтелект вже нині завдає шкоди.
Ви можете стати жертвою штучного інтелекту, навіть не підозрюючи про це.
Можливо, вам відмовили в кредиті або ви не можете влаштуватися на роботу чи знайти квартиру через алгоритм.
Вас дискримінували, і ви цього навіть не помітили. Тому я думаю, що нам слід припинити економіку даних.
Навіть коли ми живемо в капіталістичному суспільстві, ми всі сходимося на думці, що існують певні речі, які не повинні бути частиною ринку.
Люди, голоси на виборах, спортивні результати. Я виступаю за те, щоб особиста інформація також була в цьому переліку.
Карісса Веліз передбачає, що конфіденційність є найціннішим товаром майбутнього.
Але справа в тому, що багато людей надають дедалі менше значення приватності - особливо в цифровому світі.
Хочеться бути частиною спільноти. Релігія раніше використовувалася для виконання цієї функції.
Однак у західних суспільствах релігія відіграє дедалі меншу роль. А люди хочуть у щось вірити, зокрема і в життя після смерті.
Ось тут з’являються технічні гіганти і пропагують ідею, що, можливо, не тільки Бог вдихає життя у душі, а є ще й інша, майже магічна сутність,
а саме: штучний інтелект, який міг би зробити те саме. І не на небі, а в хмарних технологіях.
Прагнення до безсмертя старе, як і саме людство. Сьогоднішнє покоління може досягти вічного життя.
Принаймні у цифровому світі - завдяки штучному інтелекту.
Однак запитання не лише в тому, скільки грошей ми готові за це заплатити. І яка справжня ціна за це.